[Applaudissements]
sur les abords du cours d'eau un havre
de paix pour les animaux
autour de la Meuse le fleuve qui sépare
les Pays-Bas de la Belgique les berges
sont devenus il y a une quinzaine
d'années un espace naturel protégé
[Applaudissements]
monumentaine assure qu'il y a quelques
dizaines d'années il n'y avait presque
plus de vie dans ce fleuve
aujourd'hui la nature a repris le dessus
[Musique]
parmi les facteurs qui ont poussé les
autorités à protéger le secteur des
inondations monstres qui ont frappé la
région dans les années 1990
pour éviter de futurs dommages le fleuve
avait besoin de plus d'espace pour
sortir de son lit
pour rendre auberge leur état naturel il
a fallu racheter les fermes qui étaient
installées
annuels de 7 millions d'euros qui selon
nature monumentaine a été remplacé par
des gains de 22 millions d'euros
notamment dû au tourisme
mais transformer une zone d'une
cinquantaine de kilomètres en parc riche
en plantes et en animaux coûte cher
environ 700 millions d'euros le
gouvernement néerlandais n'a déboursé
qu'une toute petite portion de cette
somme
pour comprendre comment le projet a été
financé il faut visiter ce site minier
où l'on extrait du gravier la ressource
très prisée dans le domaine de la
construction et bien présent dans la
région
le projet est donc financé par une
partie des revenus générés par cette
exploitation des activités qui au départ
ont suscité la grande d'une partie de la
population mais le consortium qui
exploite la ressource après un
engagement
il cessera ses activités c'est cette
industriel seront à leur tour
transformés en espace naturel
on se trouve de l'autre côté de la Meuse
en Belgique à un endroit où à une
certaine époque on exploité aussi le
gravier il y a une trentaine d'années
l'activité à cesser et depuis le site
est devenu une forêt
la frontière on ne peut pas voir la
frontière c'est la Meuse c'est le temps
la Meuse mais on pense pas à la
frontière trop parce que c'est vraiment
un parc et une région Catherine
scarlatine travaille pour un organisme
belge de protection des parcs son
organisation a constaté que pendant que
l'espace protégé a doublé en superficie
la biodiversité végétale elle a triplé
mais rendre auberge de Rita naturelle
comporte son lot de défi il y a
plusieurs exemples ou sécurité et
développement nature
sont difficiles à combiner par exemple
il faudrait peut-être plus de forêts
comme celle-ci mais en cas d'inondation
leur présence pourrait empêcher le
fleuve de sortir suffisamment de son lit
n’empêche vu l'état de la biodiversité
dans cette région pourtant très peuplée
les organismes impliqués dans le projet
assurent que les efforts entrepris
depuis des années ont déjà porté fruits
c'est un signe d'espoir si on gère avec
la nature oui les résultats sont là ici
Raphaël Bouvier au clair Radio-Canada
près de la Meuse entre la Belgique et
les pays